late last june a mob of blm lunatics
smashed the gate on mark and patricia
mccloskey's house
in st louis they stormed on in the
klosky's lawn and shouted threats at
them as the mccloskeys were eating
dinner the classies hadn't done anything
they didn't know anyone in the crowd
they were just the wrong color and for
that reason
they got screamed out and threatened
that's the point in which market
patricia mccloskey
went inside and got firearms to defend
themselves because if you can't defend
yourself in your own home when a mob
shows up to hurl racist epithets at you
it's not really worth living in the
country that was our view it's a view of
most people we had
actually mark mccloskey on the show two
days later he made that point he wasn't
very political at times if anything
i think he was a democrat didn't matter
that's a fundamental right
and maybe because it is a fundamental
right prosecutors in saint louis filed
criminal charges against mark and
patricia mccloskey
a few weeks later their lives changed
forever and a lot of their opinions seem
to have changed too
now mark mccloskey is running for the
united states senate as a republican in
the state of missouri
here's part of his announcement video
when the angry mob
came to destroy my house and kill my
family
i took a stand against them now i'm
asking for the privilege to take that
stand
for all of us when the fascist mob came
to my door
it woke me up i saw what the future of
america will be
if we don't all stand up right now and
defend our rights
my name is mark mccloskey i will defend
the people of missouri
you have my word i will never back
down
amazing mark mccloskey joins us now
we're happy he is mark
thanks so much for coming on boy that
moment really did change
everything for you it seems like
it really did tucker and you know i'll
have to correct one thing i've never
been a democrat that was
the the worst fake news slur that that
has been hurled at me over the last ten
months
i've always been a republican but i've
never been a politician
but you know god came knocking on my
door last summer
disguised as an angry mob and it really
did wake me up
and as i campaigned for the president
last fall and as we've continued to do
rallies and events supporting our
constitutional rights
what i've learned is that the people out
there in this country are just sick
and tired of cancer culture and the
poison of critical race theory
and the big lie of systemic racism all
backed up by the threat of mob violence
and people are just sick of it they
don't want any more posers and egotists
and career politicians going to d.c
all we hear is talk and nothing ever
changes
yeah it just seemed to me that that
people have to stand up each and every
one of us needs to stand up now
and say we're not sheep we're free
people we're going to pull the power
back to the people
and the people that need to go into
politics at every level
from the local school board like your
like your guest
john earlier today the local city
council
your mayors your state representatives
your state centers
your united states senators you have to
send people to d.c
that are willing to tell the truth
willing to fight for our freedoms
regardless of what it costs you
personally economically socially if we
don't stand up now and take this country
back
it's going away we used to talk about
the erosion of our civil liberties
in the last hundred and some days since
this administration has taken over
there's been the wholesale slaughter of
our civil liberties
and wholesale institution of what cannot
be called anything but socialism
people being paid with our money to stay
home and not work
and and our president says gee i don't
think that's taking place
it's just everything is nonsense
everything has been upside down
and it's time to straighten things back
up
mark mccluskey i appreciate it i have to
say i'd forgotten this one fact
watching the video just now of that day
june 28th
of last year you were denounced by the
washington post as a racist for
defending your house but a lot of the
mob were like pampered white kids i
guess as always
oh i don't know why i've forgotten that
of course they were
yeah oh no congratulations
all right now i'll just say you know if
everybody out there can can help out
on five ten dollars mccloskey for senate
dot com
i sure appreciate it the left's gonna
come down on us like a ton of bricks
we need all the help we can get
i appreciate your coming on thank you
mark mccloskey thanks tucker
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else